thierry alors mesdames messieurs vedette
indéboulonnable h en mairie
c'est un thierry rolland voilà j'ai sué
poliment 1200 commentaires de matchs de
foot donc 720 avec jean michel larqué 1
l'ancien capitaine des verts de
saint-etienne et bien et moi je le dis
tout de suite quand je vous regarde à la
télé avec l'arc est en fait vu un truc
génial c'est qu'en fait vous commentez
pas le match vous discuté devant le
poste comme si ce que nous chez nous et
on essaye temps en temps vous regardez
ce qui se passe sur l'écran wicona au
dollar
c'est vrai oui c'est à dire qu'on essaye
d'être 7,1 commentaires décalés les
traits d'union entre la dictature et le
mac
voilà donc nous on dit rien puisque
c'est vous qui parlez pas l'impression
de voir une bien ensemble c'est ça qui
est ça sinon mais c'est vrai à part ça
vous présentez téléfoot vous qu'on
présentait téléfoot avec mes jeunes
camarades
voilà et vous êtes l'auteur chez
flammarion d'un livre qui s'appelle la
balle au centre mesdames et messieurs
c'est les mémoires 2-1 lens et comment
on fait thierry
mais oui mais oui je le crois pas vous
avez peur tout seul bien donc je raconte
votre ville on va raconter votre vie
c'est plutôt des souvenirs que des
mémoires c'est ça ouais pompeux mais moi
oui c'est vrai oui vous n'avez pas l'âge
des mémoires encore pour moi j'espère
nom vous dit votre âge je ne dérange pas
j'ai dit dans web os est sur moi je vais
dire mais là il faut faire des calculs
simples et si ça c'est plus dur donc
c'était en 1937 et ça vous fait 64 et
voilà ça va bah oui est-ce que non mais
alors question que toute la france se
pose est-ce que vous avez prendre votre
retraite si on est bien l'année
prochaine avec jean-michel déjà il ya un
truc qui est sûr c'est quand on
continuera où on arrêtera ensemble déjà
une chose à vos sorts sont liés
maintenant je pense que si les choses
restent en l'état en continuant avait
commencé le championnat du monde à massy
mais elle va être championne
le souhaitent c'est tellement beau quand
on a été champion du monde il ya un truc
qui est sûr en tout cas c'est que
l'équipe de france aura une très très
bonne équipe l'année prochaine sans
doute meilleure que celle d'il ya quatre
ans 1
mais qu' il faudra y aller je pense
qu'il ya une équipe qui fait figure
d'épouvantail qu'il faudrait battre
c'est l'argentine l'argent si oui
l'enfant dehors de ça bien alors vous
êtes né en 1937 à boulogne billancourt à
quoi bah voilà la clinique du belvédère
de l'autre côté du parc ce qui est très
intéressant dans votre bouquin c'est bon
il ya des souvenirs de foot mais c'est
votre jeunesse votre enfance peut être
le fils de claude et de liouba alors
liouba c'est votre mère que d'une
vieille famille aristocrate russe fas
les russes en tout cas qui a fui la
révolution est arrivée en france elle
avait deux ans ben voilà bolchevique 1
et alors lui bah ça veut dire à moore en
russe est toujours en vie votre mère 88
non plus dire bonjour là oui bien sûr
mais je pense qu'elle regarde oui c'est
toute façon ma mère et mon fils il adore
votre émission abbas est gentil alors
c'est gentil et deux générations
est ce qu'il trouve pas qu'elle a un peu
copié par d'autres mon émission
dusoulier dussollier à propos il y à
fogiel il m'a dit de vous faire c'est
d'amitié
bien donc vos parents et et bijoutiers
oui avenue georges de 5,5 en face du
fouquet's alors en fait ce qu'on
découvre en lisant votre bouquin c'est
vous la jouer prolos un peu mimile comme
ça vous êtes un bourgeois
ouais enfin disons ceci est quand même
ouais enfin je suis né je suis né vous
habitiez rude washington vous me restait
une rue à putte à l'époque oui c'est
vrai ça vous étés déniaisé des on
connaît le sujet votre et athée je lui
ai dit j p engagé dans l'armée de l'air
résistants prisonniers torturés et
finalement à décéder très peu après la
guerre un jeudi trop torride et suite à
ce qu'il avait sur et du temps de la
gestapo une méningite foudroyante en
1946 voulait pas connu non si je les ai
connus mais si vous voulez j'ai bon
j'avais quand il est membre
oui j'avais le chalet avoir neuf ans
mais entre temps il y avait eu les
années de guerre dans les années de
tendre enfance et il ya un d enfin un de
mes gros problèmes dans la vie c'est que
je n'ai pas en mémoire le son de sa voix
et ça c'est très énervant gérer son
image son image oui par les frigos des
photos ouais mais mais le son de sa voix
n'en est en fait ce qui terrifie vous
prenez conscience de la mort de votre
père lorsque marcel cerdan meurt c'est
hier que le cancer dont disparaît vous
dites finalement c'est ça la mort quoi
et au moment où il est mort ça vous a
moins touché parce que vous voyez pas
beaucoup exactement oui parce que bon
quand je partais à l'école le matin et
il n'était pas encore levé quand je
revenais le soir et n'était pas encore
rentré à une et l'endroit ouais et puis
le dimanche le dimanche pour aller jouer
au foot lui l'aimé bien jouer aux cartes
donc on se voyait pas beaucoup aux
grands soumis en fait c'est la
libération quand les américains nous ont
pris dans leurs bras
restez sympa les premiers et les
premiers paquets de chewing gum les
bonbons aux fruits avec un trou au
milieu un le grand souvenir c'est
l'avenue georges 5 où vous alliez
souvent puisque vos parents étaient en
face c'est le fouquet's où aurait pu
vous paye un inverse oui parce qu'il
habitait il habitait en facilement il
habitait au 13 et puis on se rencontrait
souvent
ouais et puis un diabolo grenade oui
c'est à dire qu'il met un jour il m'a
même
amen prendre là on peut en se croisant
au milieu des champs elysées et il m'a
dit bon petit je te vois souvent alors
je lui dis c'est normal monsieur jules
puisqu'on habite l'un en face de l'autre
le 10 mai lors on est comme qui dirait
voisin un jeune homme qui dit avoir et
bien alors viens je t'offre l'apéritif
alors on a fait demi tour mais rentrer
dans le fouquet's il a dit aux garçons
françois pour moi comme d'habitude
samson anisette et magnéto avec petit
qu'est-ce que tu pourras judy un diabolo
grenadine et au lieu d'arriver à 12h30 à
la maison je suis arrivé 12h50 et c'est
ma mère m'a dit d'où tu viens j'y vivais
chez un petit portable parce que j'ai
pris l'apéro avec raimu et ne m'a jamais
crue évidemment c'est normal quand on
alors enfoncé bourgeoise un toujours à
l'école gerson dans le xvième encore pas
mal de lycée en fait ouais ce j'étais
viré way we enfants de choeur collège
britannique
oui pendant l'anglais c'est pour ça que
je dis vous nous la jouer un peu mimile
un peu non mais non attendez je suis
allé à l'école en angleterre pour
apprendre l'anglais
ouais l'anglais vous apprenez à jouer
cliquer avec un fils de maharaja oui
vous avez un uniforme vert bouteille
avec des rayures grenat
quand je pense à ce joli pressing et
anglaise pourquoi vous avez renier c'est
marrant vous est en général c'est les
pauvres qui renie leur classe sociale
moi je renie rien du tout moi j'ai
jamais rien dit moi ouais vous vous
dites que je suis bourget que je me
donnait une allure mimi mais pas du tout
ouais on me suis aujourd'hui vous la
jouer un peu comme ça je la joue un peu
comme ça parce que j'ai peut-être une
voix qui est un peu votre titi voilà
peut-être pour ça c'est peut-être pour
ça alors vous rentrez au racing
attention à la solidarité entre les tirs
et un règlement vos entrées au racing en
46 pour faire du foot visiter le mont
fans du racing que votre vespa était
peinte en bleu ciel et blanc comme les
couleurs du racing ça je regrette de la
depuis la warmouse pas été magnifique
vous descendez à la napoule
quand j'ai 18 ans après le bac philo oui
avec la vespa oui c'est loin pour
l'autoroute
l'échoppé ça m'est arrivé comme tout le
monde - vous sans doute emmenons le nom
autour des mains non juridique français
maintenant quand j'ai eu mon bac je suis
parti à jean les pins moi c'était parce
qu'il est mon bac mes parents c'était
assez logique
pourquoi pas parce que pour parler de
sexe autant
alors geneviève premiers flirts c'était
ou à paris apparaît elle allait au lycée
molière plein de bas à l'époque quand on
se tenait la main c'est déjà un exploit
la première baisse c'était beau ça donc
5 à 3 aller au cinéma je suis et les
petits bisous disant ouais mon fils à 10
ans cet homme il est couché et à 10 ans
c'est normal mais la langue mais la
veille à 10 ans et me dit que j'aurai
trois dans la soirée ou servent aussi
mort jeudi à dix ans j'ai jamais fait ça
de ma vie on mettait pas ma langue je
pense qu'on peut
dans la première vraie baise c'est
raymonde shalit aurait dit toi c'était
un homme a tenté gentil je suis devenu
un homme quoi voilà
roland je respecte beaucoup
j'espère bien en fait la vérité c'est
que vous avez toujours préféré que les
dames comme ceux qui viennent vous
chercher assassine à face à lui ça c'est
son truc ce que moi je faisais les
petites surboum 1 on écoutait où on
écoute et le jazz oh et puis moi j'étais
j'étais pas très très bon j'étais pas un
bib hopper j'étais nul et je veux danser
sur place comment je faisais des selon
lui dans sa place à moi aussi
bougez pas je restais alors le wild a
été cool je bougeais pas de la soirée
que tu frotter un peu quand même un
petit peu battant ate a rien à voir
aujourd'hui c'est l'horreur
il ya tout chaud comment ils font les
bribes est tout de suite maintenant aux
oreilles et encore je me demande
non mais vous dites qui vient vous
chercher au moins on sait ce qui va
arriver voilà oui moi mais ce qui est
beau comme l a fait le premier pas plus
que moi je suis pas content voitures
celles qui viennent c'est pas toujours
les plus belles non mais de toute façon
il faut faire il faut faire une moyenne
y en a des vers il y en a des tonnes
tous les matchs sans marquer confesse en
dehors de toutes ces conneries
une grande grande histoire en ce moment
ah bon et on respecte ça ici ici c'est
pas du tout genre à se mêler de la vie
privée des gens donc vos débuts alors
quoi
il faut dire non c'est vrai qu'au début
le poste parisien
et pour te mettre de chez vous sortez
pas du quartier vont non c'était juste
au dessus du normandy et georges briquet
mon premier patron d'un militant alors
au début vous croit flemmard mais il
croit flemmards parce que j'ai encore là
j'étais un peu timide si vous voulez je
prenais pas d'initiative
j'attendais qu'on me dise fait ceci fait
cela je le faisais plutôt pas mal mais
c'est vrai que je ne sais pas moi qui
allais qui aller à l'assaut et vous
commencez à la télé en 60 avec raymond
marcillac
c'est du moins avec roger couderc robert
chapatte ouais mais deux grands frères
et non les deux grands frères dans la
profession qui ment qui m'ont énormément
apporté vous croyez qu'on verse la
bâtisse avec eux
les cyclistes se défoncer c'est à dire
qu'il savait qu'il en prenait un petit
peu mais papa comme pas comme maintenant
eh oui c'était pas que c'est à dire quoi
vous savez je crois que de toute façon
le problème du cyclisme qui sait que si
les coureurs ne prennent rien les étapes
du tour de france au lieu d'arriver à 5
heures de l'après midi elles vont
arriver à 10 heures du soir est donc
attendu soit le système est le journal
télévisé effacés voilà c'est
mathématique
il vous pouvez pas faire le tour de
france faire 4000 km à 40 kilomètres à
l'heure sans rien prendre ça aussi c'est
impossible au foot non au foot nos
chances pour collectif c'est plus
difficile à gérer
non non tu recherchais remet en battant
mais tous les mecs curie théâtre dans
tous les mois tous les mecs qui se sont
fait contrôler il ya eu pas moins 2% qui
ont été positifs [ __ ] for april ternes
et pour tous même sans rien y faire
n'importe où déjà bien 1960 premiers jo
c'est pas d'hier
un rom as rome 60 de premières coupes du
monde au chili pas d'hier
on regardait les matches on prenait des
notes on avait dans une grande salle où
il y avait tous les commentateurs et on
recommençait et ça partait avec les
grosses galères du monde tous les quatre
ans a été rediffusé le lendemain soit de
londres soit de francs allez vous
regarder les matchs avant de les
commander elle s'érige en ré c'est pas
comme algériens toujours hélas en 62 la
france quitte l'algérie
ça vous a marqué oui beaucoup et parce
que je pense que bon c'était un problème
très très délicat à résoudre
ouais et je pense qu'il n'a peut-être
pas été résolus de la même bonne manière
enfin j'ai vu avec plaisir le l'attitude
du gouvernement du gouvernement français
ces jours derniers revers qui ouais j'ai
trouvé ça très bien vous êtes choqué par
le fait qu'ils aient des des arabes en
france et pas de français en algérie par
exemple entre autres et je pense que la
manière dont les français ont été
évacués d'algérie a été quand même une
période très difficile à vivre pour gens
parlent tout à fait à l'aise d'autant
plus que je ne suis pas je ne suis pas
pieds noirs non plus mais je les ai vus
arriver le noir
familier alors mais j'ai les amis qui le
62e je les ai vus arriver que jamais
vraiment vraiment tout le monde disait
que c'est des milliardaires et puis
quand j'en avais peut-être il n'est pas
que ça les milliardaires sont pas tendus
62 pour partir je pense aussi mais on
dit vous êtes de droite est ce que vous
assumez parce que c'est dur d'être de
droite en france aujourd'hui tout le
monde dit qu'il est de gauche
je suis tout à fait pour le président
chirac oui je vois la droite ça
commençait pas la droite et pas de
gauche chirac quand même n'at elle pas
de gauche mais enfin c'est pas là la
vraie droite qua non non mais ça mais je
ne suis pas si vous voulez me faire dire
que je suis vivant je veux rien vous
faire dire je me pose des questions je
suis pas pour le pen non non non non je
pensais pas le pen il ya des gens plus
dur que chirac
moi je suis pour chirac moi on va faire
un test est ce que vous êtes pour la
peine de mort pour les assassins
d'enfants
oui assassins de vieillard oui assassins
de policiers
oui oui c'est déjà plus dur que chirac
ah non je suis raquil contre la peine de
mort pour tout le monde oui enfin il est
contre la peine de mort parce que ça a
été votée en france dont il ya un fini
de toute manière il n'y a plus il ya
plus de peine devant enfin ce que ce que
je regrette un petit peu pour s'éloigner
un petit peu du du monde des sports
c'est que quand il ya un type qui fait
une atrocité est vraiment une atrocité
quand il est condamné à quelque chose de
deux sévères il ne le fait jamais ne la
fais jamais cette semaine alors moi je
veux bien tout ce qu'on veut mais si un
homme tue un deux trois viols trois
quatre cinq six enfants qu'il est
condamné à perpète moi je veux qu'il
fasse perpète
mais vraiment perd pas là ils font 20
ans voilà je me que si même si fait 70
80 ans moi je veux que ça change quoi
qu'il arrive c'est c'est quand même plus
dur que la mort sans doute la mort c'est
rien du tout ça franchement de seconde
et le mec est expédié tandis que 25 ans
ou 30 ans alors là oui moi je veux pas
25 ans ou 30 ans voici ici
enfin bon si quelqu'un touche à mon
gosse moi je non mais alors voilà je
vais pas faire votre procès mais c'est
vrai quand d'autres souvent ce vote
misogynie votre chauvigny les normes et
là alors
votre racisme le fait que j'ai expliqué
que je vais pas mettre tous les arts je
vous dis ça mais très très très
tranquillement en ce qui concerne la
misogynie on m'a reproché l'élimination
de enfin le renvoi d'une malgré l'eau
d'une collaboratrice du service des
sports moi j étais strictement pour rien
d'abord parce que j'en avais parlé les
les moyens c'est pour moi et je suis
prochaine je suis rien du tout je suis
soldat non première chose la deuxième en
ce qui concerne le chauvinisme bouffe
les chauvinismes de toute façon les
français demandait le che titoff qui
aime bien le football français qui se
posent devant leurs récepteurs de
télévision pour voir france je ne sais
pas moi france ix france allemagne
france angleterre il conditionné je
connais un film il ce n'est pas ne se
met pas devant leur poste pour voir
perdre à france bon quand il ya un match
de coupe d'europe avec un club français
comptera club anglais espagnol allemand
norvégien etc
ils sont tous les français pour le club
français et en suivant et ben moi je
suis l'heureux leurs témoins sur le
stade
je suis comme eux voilà vous êtes pour
marseille ou pas là bas cette année ça
va pas trop fort mais pas cette année
mais en général ce commercial je bosse
beaucoup l'accent marseillais m'bia
marseille comme j'aime bien d'autres
c'est votre équipe favorite en fait non
j'aime bien d'autres actifs tu as
compris j'aime bien qu'il fallut j'avais
on a passé de bons moments avec
marseille j'ai oublié moi je renie pas
les les grands moments passés avec telle
ou telle équipe
voilà et est la dernière chose que je
tiendrais que je tiens à dire c'est en
ce qui concerne vous avez évoqué la
sphère de leurs huîtres tunisien je
m'empresse de dire qu'il aurait il se
trouvait qu'il était tunisien mais il
aurait été de kuala lumpur il aurait été
de ses fromages et marocain serait fait
parler leur étaient dues norvège houde
de n'importe quel pays européen c'est
pareil il s'est planté il a accordé un
but du point de maradona sa fausse et la
coupe du monde puisque l'argentine a
gagné ce match 2 1 contre l'angleterre
et ensuite elle a gagné la coupe du
monde donc pour moi la coupe du moins
est faussé pour moi il a commis une
énorme erreur c'est votre bébé si la
baby sitter chez vous et une tunisienne
où elle s'appelait ohrid
voilà vous trouvez qu'il est bof racisme
les chauvins lyonnais est honnête
surtout ouais vous n'êtes pas
politiquement correct je suis comme je
suis ouais je ne changerai pas
maintenant à mon âge avancé
alors quand berlusconi dit que notre
civilisation est supérieur à l'islam et
qu'il faut occidentalisée le monde
entier vous réagissez comment est ce que
vous pensez que c'est la mission des
accidents toad que tout le monde vive
comme nous n'en sommes enfin il faut
éviter quand même que les avions à
castrés dans des tours ouais je pense
parce que là c'est quand même beaucoup
oui c'est quand même énorme procès qu'il
faut pas mais un peu les occidentalisée
quand même je sais pas s'il faut les
occidentalisée je suis pas assez fort
pour juger de cela mais ce que je sais
en tout cas d'essai que ce qui s'est
passé il ya ya trois semaines maintenant
aux états unis m'a bouleversée vraiment
la balle au centre
je plains marion